your muscles can move with full speed
and then if you push off the wall
lightly you can you fly
zoom zoom across so how does the physics
of that work for can you still play
soccer for example in space you can but
one of the most uh intuitive things that
we all learn is babies right is whenever
you throw something if i was going to
toss something to you i toss it up
because i know that it has to compensate
for the fact that that keblerian arc is
going to draw it down the you know
equations of motion are going to draw it
down
i would in space i would just shoot
something directly towards you so like
straight line of sight and so that would
be very different for any type of ball
sport is to retrain your human mind to
have that as your intuitive
arc of motion or lack of arc from your
experience from understanding how
astronauts get adjusted to the stuff how
long does it take to adjust to the
physics of this world this other world
so even after one or two parabolic
flights you can gain a certain facility
with moving in that environment i think
most astronauts would say maybe several
days on station or a week on station and
their brain
flips it's amazing the plasticity of the
human brain and how quickly they are
able to adapt and so pretty quickly they
become
creatures of this new environment
okay so that's cool that's it's creating
a little bit of an experience what about
if you go for more than 100 days
for one year for two years for three
years yeah what challenges start to
emerge in that case
so scott kelly wrote this amazing book
after he spent a year in space and he's
a twin it's absolutely fantastic that
nasa got to do a twin studies perfect
so he wrote a lot about his experience
on the health side of what changed
things like
bone density muscle atrophy
eye sight changing because the shape of
your eyeball changes which changes your
lens which changes how you see
if we're then thinking about the
challenges between a year and three
years especially if we're doing that
three year trip to mars for your friend
who asked earlier
then you have to think about
nutrition
and so how are you keeping all of these
different needs for your body alive how
are you protecting astronauts against
radiation either having some type of a
shell on the spacecraft which is
expensive because it's heavy you know if
it's something like lead a really
effective radiation shell it's going to
be a lot of mass or is there a pill that
could be taken to try to make you
less
uh in danger of some of the radiated
radiation effects
a lot of this has not yet been answered
but radiation is really significant
challenge for that three-year journey
and what are the negative effects of
radiation on the human body out in space
a higher likelihood to develop cancer at
a younger age
so you'd probably be able to get there
and get back but you'd find yourself
in the same way if you were exposed to
significant radiation on earth you'd
find significant bad health effects as
you age
what do you think about
like decades do you think about decades
or is this like an entire i think about
centuries
for myspace but yeah for decades
i think as soon as we get past the
three-year mark we'll absolutely want
somewhere between three years and a
decade we'll want artificial gravity
and we know how to do that actually the
engineering questions still need to be
tweaked for how we'd really implement it
but the science is there to know how we
would spin
habitats in orbit generate that force so
even if the entire habitat's not
spinning you at least have a treadmill
part of the space station that is
spinning and you can spend some fraction
of your day in a near to one g
environment and keep your body healthy
wait literally from just spinning from
spinning yeah centripetal force so you
generate this force if you've ever been
in those carnival rides the gravitrons
that spin you up around the side that's
the concept and this is actually one of
the reasons why we are spinning out a
new company from my mit lab spinning out
that was accidental but well
well noted space pun is a composite
all right um but yeah we're spinning out
a new company to look at next generation
space architecture and how do we
actually scale humanity's access to
space and one of the areas that we want
to look at is artificial gravity
is there a name yet yep there's a name
we are brand new we are just exiting
stealth mode so your podcast listeners
will literally be among some of the
first to hear about it it's called
aurelia institute
aurelia is an old english word for
chrysalis and the idea with this is that
we humanity collectively are at this
next stage of our metamorphosis like a
chrysalis into a spacefaring species and
so we felt that this was a good time a
necessary time
to think about next generation space
architecture but also starfleet academy
if you know that reference from star
trek
you